see obviously uh regie had it going you
guys try to get the ball out of his
hands he continued to make plays DeAndre
continue to make plays like what was the
challenge of just getting those guys to
be uncomfortable uh
tonight um just you know early on Reggie
getting downhill getting to his spots um
put a lot of pressure on the defense and
then like I said deandre's rolls you
know down the middle of the floor L man
was late all night we wasn't able to get
there in time and once he takes off it's
you know it's too late so um defensively
you know um we didn't do a really good
job but just um understand what we're
trying to do we were trying to take away
that we blitzed a little bit more in the
second half and um still wasn't very
good in the blitz um so like I said they
was going to come in and play hard they
going to compete and then just tonight
offensively I just thought we were were
nasty offensively too slow too
methodical and only taking 23s um not
really getting to what we wanted to get
get into so um that's me I take full
responsibility for you know offensively
um well and defensively as well but
offensively just it was a nasty flow to
the game and it was too slow you guys
built double dig leades of both of those
halfs like what in your mind uh led to
the success that enabled those leades to
happen in the first place defense you
know come out of timeouts up 11 I think
start the fourth they hit a three um
coming out again our timeout up 11 we
don't we're not supp to switch we switch
both guys go Reggie hits a three and
just a lot of miscommunication on the
floor you know and so um you know guys
are frustrated you know offensively but
they should be frustrated defensively as
well like that's when you should get mad
it's on the defensive end but I take
full responsibility like I said and um
yeah we're just not going to play this
style of
basketball